dans certains pays africains de
nouvelles campagnes se font jour
elle prône tout simplement l'abstinence
sexuelle des campagnes qui émane des
églises évangéliques qui sont en pleine
expansion envoyés spéciaux bertrand cocq
frédéric ranque est l'abstinence est la
meilleure méthode de ce camp bleu
professeurs lors d'un cours
d'information sur le sida le vih est un
tueur d'ambition répétait-il devant des
adolescents à qui il prêche aussi le
respect du corps et la patience donc
attache de la valeur à son futur évitera
toute activité sexuelle
nous sommes dans un collège évangélique
et des environs de lagos il appartient à
la plus grosse église pentecôtiste du
nigeria un pays de 130 millions
d'habitants dont trois millions et demi
infectés par le virus du sida pourquoi
nous donnons à ces jolies des armes de
refus pour pouvoir dire non au sexe sans
se sentir coupable
madame adenuga et la directrice de rat
pack une ong créée par l'église pour
lutter contre le sida aides aux malades
aux orphelins information et prévention
nous ne pressions pas le préservatif
sous pression la bonne conduite a créé
le sexe c'est une bonne chose
j'ai commandé par dieu mais qui n'est
pas supposé être mal utilisé c'est ce
discours sur l'abstinence jugé
irréaliste par tous les spécialistes de
la maladie que les jeunes de l'église du
rachat font passer auprès de la
population
comme ce jour là sur un marché je leur
conseille d'éviter toute relation
sexuelle pré maritale rien jusqu'au
mariage
outre la parole les armes de ces
prosélytes sont des petits livrets
d'information et autres manuels de bonne
conduite des outils financé en grande
partie par les états unis à travers leur
agence pour le développement usaid
depuis quelques années l'administration
américaine réserve en priorité ses
subsides aux organisations qui prône
l'abstinence et la fidélité
le message est double dans un monde
dominé par le sexe
tous ne seront pas sauvés